la situation sécuritaire au mali abordé
avec nous une star deuxième vice
président du conseil national de
transition malien l'opération barkan n'a
pas été efficace selon lui
malgré la présence de 3000 un peu plus
de 3000 soldats français malgré la
présence d'un vide
un militaire étranger sur le terminal
est limité à 20 litres est la situation
sécuritaire ne s'est pas améliorée les
attentats se sont poursuivies plusieurs
parenté du territoire national demeure
sous contrôle de forces obscurantistes
et on se pose la question de
l'efficacité ou même de la pertinence de
cette opération mais comme ce sont les
autorités françaises qui in latéralement
ont décidé de de se décider pour nous
d'organiser la fois où nous nous prenons
à créer monde en tirant en tirant toutes
les conséquences
nous allons réorganiser notre stratégie
en fonction de ce que
sur le trait